simulation de noyade d'un glace et
privation de sommeil alimentation par
voie rectale on est en pleine période
d'halloween mais ce n'est pas le
scénario d'un film d'horreur que je vous
décris c'est une variété de méthodes de
torture apparemment utilisée par la cia
pour obtenir à des informations de
détenus de la prison de guantanamo c'est
le cas d'un ancien messager d'al qaïda
un pakistanais de 41 ans qui a émigré
avec sa famille aux etats unis ils la
racontent aujourd'hui les sévices qu'il
a subis depuis sa capture en 2003 il dit
avoir été suspendu par des chaînes
pendant plusieurs jours d'affilée nues
et sans rien à manger dans une cellule
sans fenêtre il décrit aussi à des
interrogatoires violents le visage
cagoulé plonger dans des bains d'eau
glacée la tête maintenue sous l'eau
jusqu'à ce qu'il parle il me frappait
jusqu'à ce que je les supplie d'arrêter
le pire c'était de ne pas savoir quand
les coûts allaient venir ni d'où ils
partiraient ses interrogateurs ne se
serait pas arrêté là il aurait aussi
menacé de s'en prendre à sa famille et
de violer sa soeur il aurait aussi subi
des lavements forcée entre deux
interrogatoires et aurait été nourri de
force par une sonde anale lorsqu'ils
étaient en grève de la faim j'ai été
violée par des médecins de la cia alors
que j'ai été ligotés ils ont introduit
des tubes et des objets dans mon anus
majid khan avait été recruté par des
membres de sa famille appartenant à al
qaïda pendant une visite au pakistan il
est passé aux aveux quelques jours après
sa capture le 5 mars 2003 à karachi il a
reconnu avoir participé à une tentative
d'assassinât du président pakistanais et
avoir remis 50 mille dollars à des
membres d'al qaïda en inde n'hésites une
somme qui aurait contribué à financer un
attentat contre un hôtel il vient d'être
condamnée à 26 ans de détention par un
tribunal militaire américain et compte
tenu d'un accord passé avec le juge
lorsqu'il a plaidé coupable il pourrait
être libéré l'an prochain chaque fois
que j'étais torturée je leur disais ce
que je pensais qu'il voulait entendre je
mentais pour que les violences
s'arrêtent mais plus coopéraient plus je
parlait plus j'étais torturée cela fait
près de vingt ans que je suis détenu est
maintenu à l'isolément j'ai payé cher je
rejette al qaïda je rejette le
terrorisme malgré la gravité des actes
dont il a été jugé coupable
majid khan ne méritait pas un tel
traitement selon son avocate
ni lui ni aucun autre les mots forts de
madjid révèle les atrocités dévastatrice
commises par notre propre gouvernement
au nom de notre sécurité nationale le
programme de la cia a été un échec il
était contraire à nos principes
démocratiques et à l'état de droit c'est
sûr qu'on attend mieux d'une démocratie
supposé montrer l'exemple en tout cas la
condamnation est la même du côté des
nations unies en décidant de ne pas
engager de procédure contre les crimes
perpétrés durant les interrogatoires de
la cia les etats unis sont en claire
violation de la convention contre la
torture et envoie un dangereux message
de complaisance et d'impunité aux
officiels des états unis est au tour du
monde guantanamo fois un univers
carcéral de l'horreur créé sur une base
américaine à cuba par george w bush
après les attentats du 11 septembre 2001
aujourd'hui 39 détenus fille sont
incarcérés sur un total de 780 à y avoir
déjà séjourné
la plupart d'entre eux sont incarcérés
pour une durée indéterminée en l'absence
d'un quelconque procès équitable empêché
par le congrès barack obama n'a jamais
réussi chez à tenir sa promesse de
fermer guantanamo et ce n'était pas dans
les plans de son successeur donald trump
bien au contraire la torture fonctionne
et si elle ne fonctionne pas il la
mérite pour ceux qui nous ont fait alors
qu'en sera-t-il de joe biden en 2009
lors de la conférence de munich sur la
sécurité
il est alors vice président il confirme
la promesse de barack obama de fermer
cette prison